[Music]
mr. James Charles age 19 once a crowned
prince of cosmetics he soon found
himself to be a boy on the brink
after the Bengal tiger of Beauty tatty
Westbrook seized upon her prey with a
swift hand of avarice he was quickly
left cold in a shallow grave while the
masses in his doomed commune departed
for other glam guru shores his taciturn
demure turned to fiery rebellion rising
from the ashes with a list of receipts
mr. Charles broke the dams and unleashed
a torrential flood of tea upon an
unsuspecting world how did he do it
where is Tati now this is why is
Geoffrey star even here I inserted
myself into something publicly that I
shouldn't have these are just some of
the questions you might find in the h3
zone hello everybody and welcome to the
HT podcast here with my beautiful lovely
host ela of course we've got the guys in
back everybody's having a good time
everybody's enjoying the tea how you
guys feeling today you're doing good
yeah they're great thank you and of
course guys I just wanted to say
shredder is looking very cute today he's
also enjoying the tea because this week
this month has been a tea tea pocalypse
it's been the tea pocalypse it's been
unbelievable now I think a lot of people
are moved on past this James Charles
thing but I'm not moving past yet
because since we made our last video
James has responded with receipts as
they say got him like the biggest tea
drama channel ever we're gonna have to
revert after this but this can't be our
permanent identity let's just have fun
with it
yeah well we can you know James Charles
came back with all this evidence showing
that Tati was super manipulative if
downright
lying about a lot of stuff and then
Jeffrey star starts coming in and
calling I'm gonna keep track of Oh
Jeffrey star comes in starts calling
James a danger to society pedophile a
predator and I think we all we can't
really let this go because J these two
guys were accusing James of such heinous
actual crimes they will not only wanted
to destroy him they wanted to send him
to jail and now all the sudden when
James responds with all this proof that
they're lying
they to those two guys are all of a
sudden about peace and harmony and love
you know guys I have I could totally
bring the receipts but I think it's time
I think it's time that we just step back
and and grow up
that's like Jeffrey stars video yeah I
bet you healing yeah I bet your ass
would like to do some healing you know
so I got a I got a say my piece for
James Charles who came riding on the T
Rapids soaked he lost so many
subscribers he's back now he's back in
the screen and Tati is in the red
actually she just posted a new video I'm
curious she posted on old video she had
pre-recorded and I'm curious if if she's
gaining or losing as a result of that
related she said hey guys I have this I
want to you know yeah she's that's what
I wanted to see I'm not and you know
what I'm not a beauty guru I'm not here
for peace love and positivity I'm here
for tea and I want to see people die and
that's what the h3 podcast teapot
podcast is all about the teapot this is
the tea podcast because I feel like Tati
she's trying to she's trying to weasel
her way out of this now that it's
completely backfired on her and she's
posting like this old [ __ ] Dan could you
pull up her tweet and read it to us and
I'm so glad to see people are not down
with that but the thing that really
bothers me and I think the most psycho
person out of this the most problematic
and there's anyone that this actual
danger to society that's come out of
this it's Jeffrey
I don't know anything about this guy I
don't know why people like him but his
involvement in this what is actually
shameful embarrassing dangerous and he
didn't even apologize to James he only
wanted to save his own ass he only did
in a way that kind of complemented
himself right where he's like I'm owning
to my mistakes before going any further
and I'm gonna be the better one here and
just back off yeah and when it should be
like no I'm apologized to James but
we're gonna get into all that you guys
can draw your own conclusions but
Jeffrey star is someone that in my
opinion seems like a dangerous lunatic
and Wow but taut seas are getting the
brunt of it as well she should you know
so guys not only that okay we've got
this phase lawsuit of one of the phases
biggest members is suing phase for
predatory contract
we've got Jake Paul calling Cody Koel
for being a cyber bully we've got Game
of Thrones being the worst show of all
time yeah we're gonna get to all that
and more here at the HT pot podcast
podcast the HTTP pot don't stay but if
you say something hot by itself you get
demoralized
Susan busted that door like the kool-aid
man and [ __ ] chokes me out yeah
careful yo were you after Tottie's
latest tweet or that came along with
this yeah where she said she's posting
on old video because she wants to heal
and prayed right yeah it's it's been two
weeks since we played with we played it
make you wait did you looked at me I
miss you all I've just posted a video I
filmed three weeks ago I hope it
provides a little escape and a little
happiness I'll get back to filming new
videos soon love you all so much and for
those reasons amount don't like you
she's such a phony
let's go but before we get into all that
oh and thank you to our sponsors third
love cap Tara and expressvpn they're
truly the greatest guys I want to give
them a cup of tea and love the art
sponsors but first guys I want to ask
you the ultimate question because we're
about to get in some serious tea
and I thought I'd break it up - you ever
catch poop in your hand before splashes
in the toilet okay cuz we had a lot of
poop conversation it said that really
quick yes let me show you a clip take a
deep breath you turn we found out a
regular question we've talked about
pooping habits on the show a lot before
- a lot of people's distaste they can't
handle it people don't like it I
personally I like it well can I say it
is my show after all but we've pretty
much exhausted the conversation that is
until I saw this clip recently on the
Internet
now if this guy's kidding is up for
debate
just like my hunch is that he's not
because one he never corrects the record
he never says because you don't want
people believing that you [ __ ] in your
hand yeah so he's no reason to lie about
it or to joke and he never he never back
pedals and his he surprised that nobody
else knows what he's talking about in
the same way that when I first learned
that people wiped from the back or that
when I lifted my balls and I was like
nobody knows very true to me with that
being said I love that I love that mate
letting the doodoo fall boil it is
crazier than [ __ ] in your hand I
don't know
so y'all just sit this [ __ ] right come
right out
[Laughter]
[Music]
interesting so here's what I think
this will guy I think is trying to solve
a problem which when you when you poop
in the toilet
the splash yes now you can instead of
putting it on your hand put it in the
toilet
ya know I have a friend in college who
taught me that cuz I always was having
water splashing on my ass and he I
really do owe him a gracious favor
because he's taught me if you take the
cover or toilet paper and you put it in
the toilet yeah you will not split it
will not splash and that really did
change my life I never thought about
[ __ ] in my hand to prevent that
because that's the whole point is to
avoid [ __ ] or water touching you yeah so
but I've never heard of anyone how could
I even catch it yeah I think he just
shits he probably puts the paper over
his hand but he makes it sound like [ __ ]
always touch his hand he's like [ __ ] you
touch it every day that's why we wash
our hands
pretty incredible stuff but I think it's
a testament to really the diversity of
of methods I think that's not what I
would recommend but I'm but again I'm
you know there's diversity of method I
don't think it was no I don't think so I
don't think so either he's a good guy
okay that guy like carbs up so he's
probably taking some oh my gosh it's I
can't imagine putting dier dier eating
in your hand though yeah that's one
reason you know that shares one reason a
lot of the comments on this video were
like he could come the next day and make
a statement that he was drawing and that
he was not drawing and I would still
think something's up like I don't know
if I said that right yeah no you said
that right yeah I was gonna say the
opposite I my reaction is if he comes
out and says he was just kidding imma
believe that guy shits in his
and stuff like I'm on the opposite
spectrum I think just cuz it's so unreal
but I think that's a man whose parents
just failed him like he was he's like a
feral child who was raised by wolves
like he was put in a bathroom and as a
child let's say you're 5 years old and
you're just learning to [ __ ]
you see toilet paper you see a toilet
and you kind of just got to figure it
out for yourself and then all sudden
you're like well I'm gonna put the
toilet over my hand I'm gonna show you
know we have weird ways of fairy that's
why we need guidance that's not why we
need our elders are our elders to guide
us through this world for through this
life to show us how things are done
because otherwise we end up shooting on
our hand like this guy so I see this as
a failure of his parents I see this as a
beautiful diversity of activity in the
bathroom we actually did a poll last
night to find out how many people a lot
of respondents 53,000 respondents so far
almost 54 Wow so we asked our viewers
for the podcast tomorrow and please be
honest this is a rigorous scientific
Twitter poll remember these are all
anonymous votes do you catch your poop
with TP obviously otherwise you know
what is it for not animals yes so it
doesn't splash in the bowl so me I'm no
never
I can't are you kidding me it's not
letting me see the results down I could
just read them out to you the poll is
not closed actually so no but once you
vote you can see they're uh well I'll
read it off to you it's 78% no never
10% a decent chunk I have once or twice
and then we have 4% whenever I am able
to an 8% every time don't let you look
you like those people are trolling yeah
what does whenever I am able to even
mean you know when the option is
available some point you know what if
there's no toilet paper sure I guess
yeah but I feel like there is actually
maybe 10% I think that is a truthful
somewhere around that 10% actually poop
like that yeah there's one
representative of that group on this
crew okay I knew when I put this
pull out that Zach was gonna somehow be
involved in this so Zach talk talk I do
I do not [ __ ] my hand I did have an
event over the beginning of this week
that this week this week yeah that's to
soak a cooker dude I know it's a
coincidence so it's gonna get graphic
so Iowa I was constipated all right and
there was this one piece that can come
out so I tried to make my own squatty
potty put my feet up on the trashcan
like it just was not coming out so I
took a baby wipe go ahead tried to pull
it out and it came out so does that
count
no extract that's just yeah that's you
being paid from you need some Metamucil
or something man at your age that ain't
right I know you yanked this [ __ ] out of
your ass that's not the same I've been
since the pregnancy I've been
constipated but I started taking
Metamucil and I'm fine
did it works huh I take it with every
meal now like through two to four of
those capsules and it's ro is so it's
amazing I get them as a sponsor that's
come on reach out to them down or the
rock tour agency we're already talking
about this mm-hmm
I've also I I don't need baby wipes
anymore you still use it though you end
with why I don't know why because it now
you don't that's what Chris D'Elia was
saying Yeah right right almost like
every time it's like the clean wipe it's
unreal
yeah well so I always end with a wet one
that's my ethos in life but I it's
definitely helped because before there
was times before where I would even go
to three for wet ones because it was so
nuclear you know yeah I know
so idea I can't endorse that product
enough now everyone else who is waiting
for us to talk about James Charles got a
gem massive poop conversation let's move
on okay I am proud of James Charles
because his apology video he came out
with was kind of pathetic it was kind of
sad and
and sloppy he was jet-lagged he was in
Australia flying back and I thought that
was it mm-hmm but boy this glam guru he
put on his makeup he came out glamorous
as hell and he went to war with these
[ __ ] and I couldn't be prouder of him
that he stood up for himself that he
shut this whole drama down and basically
exposed them for what they are and a lot
of us in the community had suspicions
that Tati was a little naughty a lot of
this stuff didn't add up
mm-hmm why is the 37 year old woman
trying to destroy a 19 year old who she
considers herself a mother of and like
there were just a bunch of little
accusations but nothing concrete stuff
like oh talking about personal [ __ ] like
oh I was at with your parents and you
were inappropriate in front of them
okay you hit on straight boys okay oh
you promoted my competitor but it's not
about that also here's a link in the
description even though it's not
monetized okay I'll tell you what by the
way before we get into it I made a nice
slope she may not have monetized her
video but she sure as hell did monetize
our video she claimed our highlight and
by the way I gave her a ample
opportunity to rectify the situation I
gave her a week to drop it before I
brought it up on Twitter but she
freaking claimed our highlight like
Hello I know that then that's an can be
an accident the claim but I disputed I
gave her a week to resolve it before I
said anything because of the beautiful
cop racism she has a month to sit on it
a month sorry I got a kid on the way I'm
trying to get paid mm-hmm I gotta give
you a month so she says it was an
accident okay well let me ask you this
then how do you accidentally and maybe
you know the answer this Yili how do you
accidentally file a DMCA because another
person who made a video
her she filed a DMCA takedown strike
added video removed that you don't do
right no sir
manual and you are very very very much
aware of what you're doing no sir
weird so I smell a little bit of also
censoring censoring trying to control
you know once those tweets went she
dropped both of them she dropped both of
course because Glam do he doesn't
understand she's she's on one part of
the community she's with the tea ladies
and they are menthe they are monsters
the community channel she doesn't know
about us we're monsters what'd I say
yeah commentary she doesn't know about
the monsters on the other side of the
pond which is the you know commentary
community there's one cardinal sin in
the commentary channel community do not
claim and well most of all don't fly or
strike it doesn't matter what they say
it doesn't matter how they say it if you
strike a video or claim a video you have
committed the cardinal sin and mask off
MMS scare off so she kind of I don't
know man Totti you're done I don't like
her man she's a phony now let's go over
James's video here a little bit step by
step let me show you how thoroughly he
eviscerates her video on the sugar bear
conspiracy let me show you this excerpt
we'll start here from the top you went
to Coachella somehow had a security
issue and magically sugar bears there
with a contract in hand to save the day
for you and all of your friends no
company would ever go out of their way
to have an extra you know handful of
passes that cost thousands of dollars
apiece first of all that is such an
assumption if anyone would it would be a
big company and if they would give it to
anyone it would be someone
like James taught the bigots you know
nobody would have dude these people have
like million-dollar partnerships
thousands of dollars all the sudden
thousands of dollars you have a thousand
drawers behind you a thousand dollars
nobody has that kind of money you know
that's such a stupid point like if we
were trying to go anywhere let's say
there's III here or whatever those kind
of events yeah
and you're trying to get tickets you
would get it from a brand bro people or
how so stupid like just in case that
leads me to believe that this was
orchestrated beforehand but he had an
emotional conflict so she's got this
whole conspiracy theory that James says
that on the spot he wanted a artist pass
and she goes oh really that doesn't make
any sense you were clearly conspiring
with them beforehand because who would
have a who would have extra passes yeah
no also the moon doesn't exist yeah
explained that he decided to go to the
second weekend all at him I'll let him
explain it to me and promises he made to
me behind the scenes so he had to come
up with a very clever story and didn't
tell this good to you but after the
little bit was very clever story it
really did happen on the spot the second
Barrentine texted me their proposal
right away no money was involved and
with no time to negotiate in a panic I
signed by the way he I love James now
I'm a fan and the first one is apology
video he's like I I'm so hmm like he's
talking so slow and then when he's on
the war he's like girl get back at it
again I'm like whoa I love it and it's
40 minutes late and exactly of like a
roller coaster by James Charles he had
nine days after Coachella to talk to me
on Monday April 22nd which was one day
after Coachella I was due to post my
stories based on my contract
and up until that moment I honestly had
not thought about the fact that taught
to you was to shake her hair a
competitor and in that moment I thought
that as a friend she deserved a courtesy
tax to let her know the context on the
sponsorship and everything that was
going on to not even get a phone call to
not even get a text a few days prior but
right after that sponsored post went up
to have a text like hey mom love you I'm
stressed just so you know XYZ I just did
this post but it's no big before posting
my stories I actually did text talk to
you first out of respect for her I can't
I read all these but basically I want to
let you know that I have to post a boy
or stereo today they saved me at
Coachella yada yada yada she said this
breaks my heart
whatever yada yada it but he did tell
her before also don't be so insecure
about it your product if nobody's buying
your product it's not because he did one
story about sugar bear whose your
product sucks it's one story and he did
a feel for her - so what's the diff and
you'll do more if you guys are friends
and whatever that's like ELA divorcing
me because I'm wearing a supreme shirt
yeah
and then try to destroy my career the
receipt says there was a flight to San
Francisco by the time that I had landed
a one hour later talk to you - uploaded
all of her Instagram joys of her crying
at talking about the friends the
community that haven't really supported
her how she was alone and how she felt
very very hurt and betrayed very quickly
people put two and two together and
realized that this was clearly about me
and I started getting thousands and
thousands of tweets and comments and
texts about the whole situation
throughout the next several hours I made
countless attempts to text both Tati and
her husband James and many phone calls
as well trying to reach them all of
which they did not respond to and later
on that night while sitting in my hotel
in San Francisco because I could not
reach don t is you a public apology
directly on my Instagram because there
you go that what she says happened is
wildly wildly different than what
actually happened and he's got the
receipts sisters das right so there you
go lie
number one she said that he never
reached out he never did anything all he
did was post the story that only
happened after days of trying to contact
her and her husband because she had
already snapped it was like I'm gonna
destroy this little [ __ ] for daring to
make an Instagram story about one of my
competitors and he does explain before
this part that he just basically decided
to go to the second weekend
spontaneously so they bought the VIP
tickets but the VIP like many people can
buy it anyone would buy it just it
wasn't enough right so that's why it was
stuck like that yes that makes sense and
he knew that one of his sons of [ __ ]
and one of his friends he knew got
Baxter our artist passes from this
company sugar bear and so he says hey
can you put me a touch I wanna see if I
can get an artist pass because it's
really rough for me here and they do
have an artist pass who has a who excuse
me who has extra passes and he got him
through them I would have done the same
freaking thing dude mm-hmm
they wouldn't giving it to me but I
would have done tried my Cuza who girl
can I get artist passes who sorry who
they be like to me who has extra passes
like so now next up so that hope that
holds BS now it gets really bad these
accusations of him preying on straight
men okay were were one of the most
compelling and troubling things and
here's when he addresses them it mostly
hinges on the accusations of this waiter
Sam who James met look at how to deny up
to the drama are you impressed I'm tuned
in as well yeah I mean look at me I'm
like a 15 year old girl all over again
so James went out with Tati on her
birthday dinner there's a cute waiter or
bartender something that James is
flirting with eye contact okay and then
in the video she's like what is wrong
with you he's straight and you are
forcing yourself on him and making him
seem like he's really a predator
well the DM show and this is really
fascinating and Jeffrey star this was
one of his main points was saying that
James is a sexual predator I danger to
society because this guy Sam he locked
in his hotel room and wouldn't leave
even though he knew he was straight well
listen to James talk about it here
telling me about a situation that
happened in Seattle at my birthday and
it literally made me want to vomit oh my
god you tried to trick a straight man
into thinking he's gay yet again and
somehow you're the victim you know it's
really disgusting to manipulate
someone's sexuality especially when they
are still you know emerging into
adulthood
how old is James by the way 19 19 right
20 years of yesterday I'm merging into
adulthood from the 27 year old lady shut
up I don't know I have everything
figured out you are using your fame your
power your money to play with people's
emotions okay you're doing that to have
them behave sexually in your favor even
if they're straight and you know what
that's not okay and how dare you laugh
about it and make me master me man
between this and that and I love
straight boys I love straight boys and
men this behavior is not normal it's not
okay
cracking someone's sexuality is not an
escape room first of all I am a 19 year
old virgin I talk about boys quite a lot
of my social media networks clearly at
this point it is a virgin mean being gay
by the way I was wondering no BUTT STUFF
does that mean that he's never had a
dick
what like like no oral stuff would that
make you still virgin I don't think so
but I think I think no inner-court no no
no how would you say penetrate no
penetration either receiving or giving
that's my guess that's my guess as well
but it's kind of I think it's kind of
sorry guys sorry shredder so but I
thought it was kind of in tearing how he
came out he's like listen I'm a virgin
yeah do we have to take a break then uh
two minutes okay let's just do it then
we'll continue on with this but man he
crush he shuts this down he shuts it
down I mean I love this when I watched
this video I was like yeah squeeze
Totti is this I don't like her from the
first minute and now I'm sure of it
we'll be right back guys
Eva have you ever had difficulty finding
the right bra to fit every breast every
single time and when you get the wrong
bra how much of a pain in the butt is it
or a pain in the boobs you could even
say it's not right you've got all these
sizes of ABCD what about all everything
in between it's not right and that's why
third love exists because third love
uses data points generated by millions
of women who have taken their fit
finding quiz to design the perfect bra
with breast size and shape in mind for a
perfect premium feel every dang time
third level offers more than 70 sizes
including their signature half cup sizes
for just when you have 1/2 cup of build
all the traditionally you gotta take a
full cup a boob sex your size exactly
you'll other change in the game fit find
your quiz they've got a quiz that you
answer simple questions to find your fit
and it only takes 60 seconds over 12
billion women have taken the quiz today
it's actually fun and takes less than a
minute to complete did you know that
your breasts shape matters when finding
a good fit third love helps you identify
your breast size and shape and find
styles that fit your body it's got a
100% satisfaction guarantee
every customer has 60 days to wear it
wash it put it to the test and if you
don't love it return it and third level
will wash it and donate it to a woman in
need see that's nice I like that they
donate it they don't incinerate it it's
really thoughtful but you get your money
back it's risk free either way third
loves team of experts fit stylists are
dedicated to helping you find your
perfect fit you can even text chat or
phone call them returns and exchanges
are free and easy so what the heck are
you waiting for their love knows that
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they are offering my listeners
15% off your first order go to third
love comm / h3 now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love.com slash h3 for 15%
off today
finding the right software can be a
challenging endeavor because it takes so
long to get it set up
you got to install it you got to pay for
it you can do all this and then you
realize that's not the right software
for you you know what you really need is
a hub for reviews with software you can
find software read reviews and make sure
you're getting the right one and that's
the beauty of kaptara kaptara is the
first free online resource to help you
find the best software solution for your
business with over eight hundred and
fifty thousand reviews of products from
real software users discover everything
you need to make an informed decision
search more than seven hundred specific
categories of software everything from
project management to email marketing to
yoga studio management software my
friends that's as niche as it gets
yoga studio management software you can
I cannot be used for anything but yoga
no matter what kind of software your
business needs kaptara makes it easy to
discover the right solution and fast so
join the millions of people who use
kaptara every month to find the right
tools for their business now I've had
trouble all throughout building these
businesses finding the right software
you got organizational issues content
management systems
you've got unis bookkeeping stuff you
need a iyx I mean it's ridiculous you go
to kept area you type up what you're
looking for
you're gonna find a bottom credible
breadth of availability and reviews the
people are gonna tell you which one to
try based on their real experience go to
kaptara comm / h3 for free 2-day to find
the tools to make it in forum software
decision for your business kaptara comm
/ h3 kaptara that capt erra comm / h
through finding the right software can
really change the game and i hope that
you will find that over at capcom / h
lee
admit it you think that cybercrime is
something that happens to other people
you may think that no one wants your
data or that hackers can't grab your
password and credit card details well
guess what just because you're single
and broke doesn't mean hackers don't
want your data because stealing from
unsuspecting people on public Wi-Fi is
one the simplest and cheapest ways for
hackers to make money when you leave
your internet connection unencrypted you
might as well be writing your passport
and credit card numbers on a huge
billboard for the rest of the world to
see that's why I decided to take action
and protect myself from cyber criminals
I'll use Express VPN its first VPN
secures in tanana misers your internet
browsing by encrypting your data and
hiding your public IP address expressvpn
has easy to use apps to run seamlessly
in the background of your computer phone
or tablet turn on expressvpn protection
only takes one click using expressvpn I
can safely surf a public Wi-Fi without
being snooped on or having my personal
data stolen for less than seven dollars
a month you can get this very same
expressvpn protection that I have
expressvpn
is rated number one VPN service by
TechRadar and comes with a 30-day
money-back guarantee so protect your
protect your online activity today and
find out how you can get three months
free and expressvpn Calm / h3 that's exp
or e SS VPN dot-com / h3 for three
months free with one gear package visit
expressvpn dot-com / h3 to learn more
hmm welcome back I had a funny
realization during the break
I think Tati is like the villain from
Snow White
it's like mirror mirror on the wall
who's the prettiest of them all and then
the mirror is like it's James Charles
prettiest and then talked is like I will
destroy him I must be the purtiest
also taught C's name on all of our
social medias is glam life good what is
it
glam guru life alright anyway where were
we
let's let's hear James I just thought I
would bring it up put it out into the
universe I don't really get a lot of
action we have probably guessed this at
this point so that being said I have
never and would never and will never use
my fame money or power to manipulate or
get any sexual actions from a guy that
is disgusting it is not me and the fact
that taki brought this up blows my mind
because she knows the real story the
story that we're talking about here is a
situation that happened when I was in
Seattle for talk to a surprise party
with a boy named Sam now I'm going to
tell you the full story since everybody
it seems to be leaving out literally
every single detail in doctor's video
she mentioned that she was disgusted and
how to apologize to her family for me
apparently saying things that I wanted
to do to a waiter and then just to find
those actions by saying I am a celebrity
okay this literally did when I heard her
say that I even thought that must be a
joke
mm-hmm yeah she's like she and her and
her retelling she owes I was like James
you can't say that he's straight and you
know what he said to me it's okay I'm
famous and even in her [ __ ] tone I was
like that sounds like a joke you know
and sure not what did happen
is that me Jeffrey Nate - my best friend
drew all flew to Seattle - surprise talk
to you for her birthday on February 14th
that night we went out to dinner with
that with Tontine James and her whole
family and we're in a restaurant there
was a cute boy across the restaurant
that I kept me icon
with and that I was interested in and
the conversation of dating for me and
Jeffrey both keen of the dinner table
and we were talking about it for a very
very short period of time the
conversation never got inappropriate
period the boy that was involved in the
story is named Sam now when I originally
wanted to do this video addressing
everything I did plan on crossing his
name and keeping him completely private
but he has since come out and made a
video of his own talking about the
situation just like talk to you leaving
out many many details but in his video
and in the screenshots that I have Sam
mentioned that he was perfectly fine and
found the flirting that I was doing
flattering so I'm not really sure why
this got turned into something much
bigger but it simply was not he was
looking at me later on that night he
started me Valentine this is this was on
Valentine's Day
where he especially thought that I was
very attractive and he wanted to get my
phone number and all that but the wait
staff at my restaurant didn't let that
happen he left and it kind of just went
I'm talking about the Imus Liberty thing
is really incredibly frustrating to me
because this is an inside joke between
my friends and I had Itachi is also
participated Tati is even participated
in he said with Tati is this the family
number literally ten people have this
number feel special I always do you do
wow you're so famous
mmm-hmm to be something far worse than
what it is this is the joke that really
is where we say I'm famous not I'm a
celebrity and a thing that we don't say
it in public very often because without
context I get it it looks and sounds
really really bad trust me
literally famous it's synonymous of
anything good so yeah my YouTube video
does well one day my friends was like oh
my god James you're so famous but
literally if my friend takes a good
instrument and it is so frustrating that
she turned it innocent and funny inside
joke does she has participated in into
something so beyond disgusting I'm going
to try my best to make it a long story
very short the next day Sampson into my
team's first
yeah we working this guy he's the one
that messaged James yeah he said that
basically at the moment he didn't know
who James was and then he went and
talked to his sister or something about
the famous and the sister was like oh
you should message him back and then I
guess basically he messaged him and he
told him that is bye and it was
interested well there you have it that's
not at all what they said mm-hmm and now
he's making videos about it's like you
got to feel almost I feel bad for James
cuz it's like dudes out here trying to
just find someone to be involved with
romantically and this you know he goes
on with his life
this guy DMS him out of the blue because
his sister told me was famous so then
they hook up he sells him he's bi they
go and hook up and now all of a sudden
not only is that guy talking about it
but everyone's calling him a sexual
predator bringing on a strake I mean
it's insanity the conversation about a
sexuality and he told me straight up
that he was bi sexual oh my god you
tried to trick a straight man into
thinking he's gay there was no straight
man at being manipulated so there you go
uh Tati what the f yeah and I guess he
goes on also to show a lot of other fake
situations that started to show up on
Twitter mm-hmm oh yeah people were
fabricating [ __ ] yeah
just straight up that happened to me
once what during my big drama when
everybody hated us I guess those people
still do hate us but but somebody what
did they do they fo yes people were
photoshopping that I blocked them yeah
because I never block people on Twitter
I never ever blocked people on Twitter I
don't think I have one person blocked
and then this guy photoshopped that I
blocked him I was like that's so weird I
he almost fooled me I went to his
Twitter account and I was like oh the
guy's not blocked or he's not blocked or
muted or anything I've never interacted
with them
[Music]
so I've seen that firsthand people do
that it's crazy and it's creepy and it's
weird but they do it I've seen it
firsthand it's myself it's just so and
then that the weird thing is like a
drama channel start picking up on it and
reporting it that's when it gets really
yeah really strange problem is when the
story gets picked up and everyone just
hears the first version mm-hmm and then
that's what stuck in their head and then
it's really hard to go and actually
convince people that wait that's not the
actual story there's more to it or
whatever people like don't care at that
point that's kind of why I insisted on
making this podcast because the gut
reaction was that James must die Tati is
the queen she's the glam life guru and
so now that the dust is settled I will
need to go back and kind of reexpose
this because the your first reaction is
like oh and then you move on because you
don't care it's not interesting and that
happens all the time
I mean now there were snap dates in
about Pro Jared yeah that one's creation
there's been a lot of dip of twists and
turns in the Pro Jared thing that so
much I do want to report on again but
I'm kind of waiting for the dust to
settle we could fall in like it closely
though it's just becoming like hard to
tell at this point because there's so
much to each side yeah and all sudden
the girl who said that her husband
cheated on her apparently it was pushing
him to do it or you know she was like to
it you know it's like how can you know
yeah yeah and was saying in text
messages that she was gonna destroy his
life yeah so you know I got a bird Jesus
so yeah this stuff happens man so now
here's another part I'm just kind of
moving along here I reach out to many
different friends for advice so here he
is get trying to get Tottie's advice
about this specific I so he's by he's
reached out to James he's interested he
messy text Tati says hey when are you
gonna come home I want your advice
Sam that's the waiters flying to LA on
Saturday she says what I know we've been
talking every single day she says you're
supposed to hook up with the waiter not
marry him
that's Tati who made a video saying that
you're manipulating straight boys who
actually knows the whole situation I
mean what the hell that's that's the
most damning part dude
that's you're in on it you're
encouraging that is just a bold-faced
lie that's just manipulating people when
you know absolutely better it's correct
but it goes on it continues on gets even
worse there was one day in my kitchen
we're taught to you James and Gabriel
all came over and I told them the same
exact story and show them the same exact
screenshots to all of you guys just saw
of him saying I'm bi hmm she said in her
video talking and James actually did
have a heart-to-heart conversation with
me about the boys that I get involved
with they told me that talking to
curious guys was going to continue to
get me hurt and that also it could look
really really bad for an outside
perspective if somebody tried to
manipulate the situation and for me this
is a major major wake-up call that I
took to heart because I honestly had
never thought about it in any other way
because I knew that everything that I
was doing was always consensual between
both me and the boy and I had receipts
to back it up but I wish I knew at the
time that Todd his advice was really a
warning yeah exactly maybe someone else
may which was telling my story with no
details no facts and no proof and
twisted around and now serious
allegations have surfaced that could
permanently damage my career you got to
love that she warns him which which
makes me think that she's been thinking
about this how to weaponize this for a
long time but you gotta love that she
she's the one that ended up using it
against him I mean with friends like
these who needs enemies right yeah my
goodness
Judas Judas guru getting Gregg am life
damn life clam life I could tell looking
at her the way she just sits there
you know she man she's in over port I
gotta say I respect James and you you
made a point about you think that what
he was doing was borderline I do think
he has a lesson to learn here when what
he was doing because that the situation
was like it was there was consent from
Sam so I'm not saying that he did
anything wrong but it is pushing a
little bit of a problematic thing when
you're a celebrity let me just say what
happened Sam went over to his hotel room
and they made out in his hotel for an
hour and then he left that's what
happened yes and then he kind of
basically kept talking to him from what
I understand and it sounds like he's
kind of confused about his sexuality
yeah Sam yeah and in a way I just got
the feeling that because he said like at
first I didn't know who it was but then
my sister was like oh it's James Charles
you should respond and I feel like that
kind of pushes you into a situation that
maybe otherwise you weren't gonna go
into and I think James needs to be aware
of that right I think it's an important
lesson for him I learned and as he said
any we received it yeah yes because you
are not just another guy you are also
famous and therefore you have the power
to influence people more than someone
else would yes sadly he is as he said a
19 year old virgin yeah and so I mean
golly you know it's tough to be mature
about those things in that age but I
think you make a great point EULA but
then the way that she twists it on him
she's on one hand giving him the advice
he needs and then on the other hand
weaponizing it again I mean who are you
what actually who are you you know I
mean it's shameless it's totally
shameless I'm glad he really explains a
while I'm glad he did because from his
point of view after that video came out
he must have just been like
flabbergasted yeah and to see his sub
count dropping by the millions and to be
able to still put himself together and
make this video mm-hmm
love it you go girl I actually think he
made a
poignant point a really fit and the
conversation to a halt immediately I do
take full responsibility for sending
these messages in this situation has
definitely taught me that sending
messages that are so for and direct like
this are unacceptable and I know so he
was criticized for sending straight men
or boys in general be like hey you're
hot stuff like that so he's responding
to that accusation a few different guys
that I've talked to in the past have
since came forward with their stories or
posted screenshots of conversations that
I had with them it saying that I made
them feel uncomfortable and reading some
of them I honestly felt really really
bad I reached out to all the boys
directly and apologize to them for my
actions
but aside from those few guys people are
training at hashtag Jam charles's over
party as an open invitation to add to
the narrative with lies which is all
harmful to me but it's also creating
very very dangerous stereotypes around
the lgbtq+ community for example zara
larsson who's a pretty big singer
tweeted saying that i messaged her
boyfriend multiple times knowing he was
straight and this tweet got almost half
a million likes before it was deleted in
her defense she did later on say that it
was only one of message but it was way
too late because the media had already
done it you can see the messages you're
really hot mm-hmm saying that I was
harassing straight men and wouldn't
leave him alone had I known he was
dating zara larsson i clearly never
would have messaged him in the first
place but this is all very hypocritical
considering in this his house are a
Larson found her boyfriend I like - I
think this is such a great point he
makes here that I actually yeah need to
acknowledge when we go back and find
that tweet I know that he was dating
zara larsson I clearly never would've
message so she said who are you where do
you live how old are you why are you so
fine
how do you like your eggs cooked in the
morning she said to him by the way that
work they're dating now that girl
thirsty as hell god damn so his house
are alerce I found her boyfriend
I'd like to post a question to you the
audience and asked why is it okay for
zara larsson a woman with the public
platform to tweet these photos of a
shirtless man and saying who are you
where do you land how old do you why are
you so far how do you like your eggs
cooked in the morning but for me as a
gay man to DM the same person in private
with a simple compliment is predatory
these stereotypes are on gay men have
been and continue to be very very
harmful to the community that have been
historically used to villainize gay men
in society someone completely fabricated
a whole tears that's a great point I
actually do think so mm-hmm
you know you you go girl
good point peanut gallery do you guys
agree yeah definitely I mean he's right
I mean that's been a thing for as long
I've been alive of like you know gay men
are gonna force themselves on you or
come after you or whatever and it's
[ __ ] and yeah I mean he like he said
I mean giving somebody a single
compliment in a private message is not
remotely [ __ ] predatory I mean that
happens every day it's a little skeevy
it's a little for a pub games Charles to
be like hey wow you're so hot we'll be
like what but but he acknowledged that
do you know yeah but I bet you were
brought up of him being famous that does
change the dynamic that's true it's
different than just you know a slight
bubble what she did was like way beyond
what he did we're doing a show here
shredder shredder chilla so anyway that
that pretty much shred do you want to go
outside we're doing a show for chrissake
so that pretty much closes what I had to
say about Tati and I think that shreddy
what are we doing here you ruining
ourselves at tea time
not good so that closes the book on Tati
and I have to say it was eye-opening
yeah I mean he really came with the
receipts with all the proof and then I
love this the reaction is always like
guys it's time for healing after they
guy called out yeah because Tati
actually we didn't let me show you let's
just put it all behind us yeah exactly
here's Tottie's final statement not this
one she said she had a really [ __ ]
response to his video when I first came
out she goes I've left town on a digital
break to heal and pray for healing on
all sides my family made me aware of
what was just posted and I'm
disappointed to see it littered with so
many lies and half-truths okay well
first of all if you didn't watch it cuz
your family told you then how do you
know it's littered with half-truths and
lies but like okay I didn't see he he
provided proof to everything he said she
said I stand by my videos do not twist
my words into what they are not hear the
message he said aka by the way she
deleted her original video so she did
not stand behind it in fact she didn't
even respond but this is always the case
he comes with proof and all of a sudden
she wants to take a break for and pray
for everybody's healing it's like do you
remember who broke this basin to begin
with Humpty Dumpty um yeah I stand by my
video whatever she just kind of own it
man you gotta apologize to him like say
you were bitter old fairly apologize
yeah just admit that you're a bitter old
hag okay that's getting passed up by
this young he's the new uh
beauty guru now and that breaks your
heart
just admit it I think it's a lot of
credit he's the 19 year old yeah and he
was under such an attack yep penny I
mean he came out a lot more mature than
the other guys girl he came out with his
hair flowing and she's print off on a
praying vacation she's all praying for
the healing of everyone yeah and taking
down videos so anyway now let's move on
to Jeffrey star who if anyone's a danger
to society as I've said it's him
Jeffrey star okay let's see here where
we begin with this guy man he goes who
else has a draft folder full of tweets
they wish they could send out I want to
keep it so real sometimes but the behind
the scenes in the beauty community but
I'll let karma do
it's work like it always does okay
Geoffrey stars I started getting tagged
in after this tweet and a few other ones
from him and his friends I decided to
reach out to him and ask if there was
something going on and that I should be
aware of he replied to me and he said
that it was not about me and that it was
about another brand stealing his ideas
this message was in a voice memo which
has since disappeared from the
screenshot you'll just have to believe
me I have literally no reason to lie at
this point even though he said it wasn't
about me I still asked to talk to him it
but he said he was unavailable a few
hours later I was getting ready and
forth and back gala I got this text from
Geoffrey concerned but mostly oh really
said we definitely need to talk soon
tatty and Shane and a few others told me
everything that you have said about me
the last six months I'm heartbroken
disgusted and so said hear about
everything but shockingly not surprised
I've only been a great friend you and
never said anything bad about you behind
the scenes which is obviously not the
case I don't know about it totally
confused I reached out town about
meeting together in private hopes to
speak together and figure out the best
understanding but he didn't reply three
days later still no response I decided
to reach out again but he was not
available to talk I flew to Australia on
May 8th
and on May 10th I was before my schedule
being reappearance where five thousand
fans were already waiting outside I was
woken up at four in the morning by my
friend because Tata had just uploaded a
video titled by a sister watching talk
to you video it was very clear tweet my
friend was still very hurt and even
though I had already apologized both
privately and publicly I wanted to make
a video right then and there with my raw
and honest emotions but because the time
difference it took me an extra few hours
to film the video and get it up and by
the time I was about to hit publish
I received yet another text I'm so
here's Jeffrey star he says are you
gonna respond to everything or pull a
mani 2.0 I'm not in deep enough to know
what that means when you so this is the
same boy he says when you basically
trapped Sam in your hotel room in
Seattle
psychologically forced him to stay and
made him feel horrible for their pennies
you spent on the room I knew something
was terribly wrong with you when Zach
showed me the snapshot message of you
trying to force him to like you and send
him photos it was completely horrifying
to see you use the same sentence as a
rapist would use he was so grossed out
by your behavior in the way that you
tried to make him feel bad for not
reciprocating the same feelings I've
already cleared up
together being Harborside consensual he
was absolutely not trapped at a hotel
room but Jeffrey also brings up Zack
Zack is his boyfriend Nate brother and
not only did I not pursue Zack who
identifies as mainly straight but it was
actually Jeffrey who suggested that I
talk to him in the first place hey minx
brother is single and mainly strange
alright if your ally by the way when a
gay guy refers to guys mainly straight
that's kind of a douchey that's Geoffrey
start kind of being manipulative towards
a straight guy to his gay friend being
like he's mainly straight you know only
if you maybe if you're famous and rich
enough you know like [ __ ] you Jeffrey
star can I check for maybe a total of 10
selfies back and forth to each other he
was super super sweet but it was very
clear to me that he was not actually
interested and the conversation sought
before anything could even get remotely
flirty at all with everything going on I
did not reply to Jeffrey's text in the
moment a few days later on Monday I woke
up again in the middle of the night from
a phone call my little brother Ian who
was very very upset he told me he had
tweeted saying why do people act so
tough online about somebody from his
hometown who was bullying him and a
Jeffrey star of all people had quote
tweeted Ian's tweet saying why is her
brother a predator why did you really
move back to New York City
exactly shut the [ __ ] up meadow that's
what Jeff Jeffrey tweeted this from
nowhere to James's good to his younger
brother younger brother here the guy he
just says why does everyone act so tough
over the Internet there's like a 15 year
old I don't know how old he is and
Jeffrey star is a grown-ass man
how old is Jeffrey start Dan he must be
in his 30s
[Music]
look like he's 80
you guys looks like a Kripke maybe I'm
wrong looks like he's 57
looks like he's 107 33 yeah 33 my age
right so don't think I'm being an ageist
here but imagine me going to a 15 year
old minding his own business say why is
your brother a predator why'd you really
move back to New York City exactly
shut the [ __ ] up what okay
who's a danger to society again yeah
this guy's calling anybody out how did
this guy have fans that's so true how
did people like that's 17,000 people I
don't understand Jeffrey's are how does
this guy have fans I mean this is really
troubling back to New York City
exactly shut the [ __ ] how do you top any
job for bullying a kid who had nothing
to do with this situation literally at
all and he deleted it the tweet after
this I went to check my phone and notice
that Jeffrey had texted me a few minutes
prior and I opened my phone to this I
really want to read this text out loud
just so you all get to hear exactly what
I had to read but also so I don't miss
anything
Grayson is going on camera shortly to
finally tell the world how you tried to
molest him and touch him in his sleep
and made him uncomfortable for months
you sick [ __ ]
next Zach will be going on camera to
tell how twisted and sick you were
trying to get him to like you and then
make him feel bad what he didn't want to
send you photos back then Sam from
Seattle will be joining me in Cameron to
talk about you trapping him in his hotel
room
you need to be locked in prison for a
very long time you need the internet
taken away from you you are a danger to
society as disgusting as it is bringing
up Graceland Dolan was pretty clever at
the high of all these allegations and
stories going around both of the twins
unfollowed me not wanting to be
associated and fans started speculating
that the rumors could be as to why I let
all these Fairweather friends I mean I'm
blown away by how everybody just dropped
James on a dime like the Dolan twins an
effort to not be associated with him
unfollowed him on Twitter like what the
[ __ ] you do [ __ ] all these people
it's like Hello stand with your friends
man at least figure out what happened he
says they reached out to him directly to
see if he was okay which is nice but
it's like god damn y'all too bad that
aside from our pre-planned collaborative
jokes that happen did the sisters want
videos me and Grayson flirting nothing
ever happened between us and when all
this went down
I knew Decker was lying because the
twins were two of the first people to
call me and make sure that I
okay I already mentioned Zack and I
still have no idea who the Cameron and
Geoffrey's referring to in this message
is but he also brought up Sam last who
he also already talked about later on
that day though Jaffrey was right
Sam did upload a video to his YouTube
channel telling the whole story he left
out almost all the details and included
an illegally recorded FaceTime call
which was on May 2nd told you remember
that but even through all of this he's
still no so anyway Jeffrey star that
vote so here by the way if you want
someone who's a danger to society
look what jeffree star tweeted out when
he was 25 years old to a 16 year old
Justin Bieber who else wonders how big
and tags him Justin Bieber's dick is
that's a 25 year old man tagging a 16
year old child like the fact that he
tagged him is even more disgusting like
he wants Justin to know that some creepy
dude is is creeping on him who was
wonders how big Justin Bieber's dick is
the [ __ ] 2010 then 25 I mean I'm blown
away by that there's a bunch of tweets
Fila see I've had so many straight boys
naked that I think I deserve a Lifetime
Achievement Award I wonder who's down to
[ __ ] tonight straight boys where you at
I like straight men not gay boys badly
don't be a jerk yeah exactly so all the
sudden calling the kettle black
I mean Jeffrey star is so psycho it's
scary
he even has Jimmy Starr even as a song
about that he's into straight boys
I mean here we go get your teacups up
[Music]
yeah straight boys to play okay he was
actually trying to make an actual
musical career this is a real attempt
that music I want to I gotta get the
lyrics wait where's the lyrics hold on
yeah artists jeffree star album plastic
surgery slumber party here I actually do
really want to find the layers put in
discord for you oh thank you so much
great one yeah I think we got Ari
sorry everybody I have to read the
lyrics to this this is way too good okay
y'all ready for this this is gonna be
good there we go
yep I want a boy with juicy lips who
doesn't care I don't have to I want a
boy like me but hotter I eat out like
Jeffrey Dahmer oof
straight boys I must confess wanna get
under my dress
give me your kiss kiss give me a fist
fist
oof straight boy I don't think any
straight boys are gonna fishmeal it all
right
hey boy he said you want the hit from
the front to the back I want a boy who
would take the blame
put Ron Jeremy to shame I want a boy
under the sheets with pink stain boxer
briefs you like you like a blood-stained
they don't have to tell their friends
they're getting it from both ends he
wants a boy with a blood stain in his
underwear oh no bro this guy's a danger
to society if anybody is alright enough
so for this guy to act of God oh no no
no no we have multiple videos playing my
panicking hold on guys everybody just
see patients why I don't see it anywhere
wait I still hear things how are we good
yeah I got it
please I was like please God make it
stop
so for Jeffrey star who says he wants
straight boys with bloodstains in their
underwear who when he was 25 tweeted at
Justin Bieber directly tagged him I
wanted who wonders how big Justin
Bieber's dick is to call James Charles
problematic is uh really something to
think deeply about we looked it up it
was it was a 16 year old Justin Bieber -
yes yes 16 year old Justin Bieber he was
25 at the time I mean that to me is just
yeah I mean my goodness gracious
not great I don't understand the Jeffrey
star stuff because that guy seems to me
to be genuinely
Terr likes like wow I don't get it but
okay there you go I've said enough about
him let's see there's more cuz this is
like the hole so then all of a sudden
this is how he responds to James video
I'll make sure I'm not make missing
anything here last but finally not least
Jeffrey posted this tweet claimed he
hadn't seen me since February and that
Nate banned me from their home
she's good and I just think it's really
funny that Jeffrey brought this up and
sorry the fact that he's tweeted me
twice and between February and now
saying that he missed me yeah that's the
only part that he said he's banned from
his house but in that period he's met -
he's message I'm saying he misses him so
after James posters video Jeffrey star
says this everyone keeps asking me for
my receipts I have so much to say and
some really sad disgusting things to
show you guys James Charles tried to
mass manipulate you all today when I
show you proof and why I tweeted that
sweet about him you will all finally
understand did I show the original tweet
that he said he's a danger to society
and everything thoughts he said is true
I think I got it here no damn it maybe
you guys can find it don't I had it
maybe this is it we know what it says we
do you just said it right yeah basically
yeah but um let's see anyway so yeah he
said he's a danger to society and
everything he taught these videos true
he basically you know got involved so
now he said I've got receipts he's
disgusting and he tried to manipulate
you except what happens next
just like Tati he puts out a video
saying it's time to heal hello everybody
the last few weeks in the beauty
commission some of our personal life is
gonna take the high road mm-hmm he
doesn't apologize to James he apologizes
to his little brother but he says I have
receipts and I will destroy you
and also when James actually defends
himself this guy's gonna take the high
road and people actually buy it that's a
very creasing I know a lot straight bull
wait hold on hold on well as this plays
I want to play straight boys yeah we
gotta we have to set that atmospheric
air okay good okay go ahead Jeffrey
where were you
I know a lot of you yeah expecting to
get a lot of tea today yes much better
right much better I think this will be
one of the most important videos yeah
and I think today I would like to shed
some light on the straight Oh sticks
from the mouth to the ass
things are getting straight boys I want
to put blood in their boxers have a
conversation straight boys I want to put
blood in their boxers don't tell anyone
and straight boys hey guys I'm so sorry
I was so immature I shouldn't have got
involved sorry I tried to destroy this
bright young boy's life and called him a
sexual predator Justin Bieber by the way
how big they how big is your dick Justin
Bieber when you're 16 straight boys a
big dick he's like vetoing I thought it
was a man anyway
Tati's final remark she says she stands
by her video I think weird he showed
this but in the end she stands by her
video and she's disappointed to see
James's video littered with so many lies
and half-truths do not twist my words
hear my message who are you Obi Wan yeah
hear my message shut up anyway she
erased her original video so how am I
supposed to hear your words if you
erased your video you know in the end I
think this is a very valuable parable
[Music]
ela you had some interesting things to
say about kind of the danger of internet
beef and hate mobs today how people are
just so quick to judgment yeah just feel
like it's been so crazy and with Twitter
it's like wildfire it's like it just
spreads so fast and everyone hears about
it and then like I was saying earlier
like no one really cares to follow up
and actually hear the full story wants
both sides you know tell their stories
so it's really dangerous it is I mean
there could be like a million people
walking around thinking that James
Charles is a pedophile well I have to
even I have to eat the crow a little bit
because in our original podcast I showed
a lot of those screenshots from James
and being like oh well sure there's a
pattern of I mean there are accusations
of him of all kinds of things that are
not substantiated so we really need we
really need to be wise about how these
things spread on the internet I mean
it's it's specifically on the internet
because things happen so fast and so
strong that we don't have any time to
actually sit back and think and reflect
it's like you said it's just a fire and
I've never seen anything like that and
I'm really glad that James had the
opportunity and that people were still
had the attention to listen mm-hmm that
he didn't take too long to address it
yeah with the projared thing I don't
think people are still care even though
there's more screen shots now and more
texts and stuff like that I don't think
anyone cares at this no or he's not as
interesting which is so Dane and it's
not as new wants to either because the
guy was definitely a creep I mean he's
got his dick out he had a putt he had a
tumbler God just sit let my little sins
sin Jared I mean yeah I just mean the
fact that it's like it's judged by how
interesting the story is at the moment
how juice is it on Twitter right now I'm
trending and then you move on it's so
crazy it's true Jared's one is tough I
mean I'm sure that that the the side
that we got that everybody reported on
is so biased like I'm sure Jared would
have a lot to say about it but
I'm glad that I'm glad that James
Charles was able to kind of come with
receipts mm-hmm
Jared on the other hand I don't know man
that guy is just I mean his dicks on the
internet what do you how do you come
back from that anyway you know say he's
completely innocent I mean dude I saw
your dick how do you come back from that
you know so yeah
what's your dicks on the Internet
especially that dick Vick like you if
you if you're nice-looking and you got a
nice dick and it's maybe you're just
walking around but the fact that he's
like full-on dick pic from below
squeeze your dick you can make it like
look bigger and harder he's doing that
and it's just all gnarly yeah Garth
likes that I managed to avoid seeing it
up until I think it was yesterday
really when somebody replied to I think
it was the Twitter poll we ran what did
you think about it sure well you know
what would you rate it on a scale 1-10 I
didn't inspect it too closely I mean it
you know maybe it was the angle but it
seemed you know at least he doesn't have
a micropenis I guess yeah it could be
worse no he doesn't have a micropenis
he's a normal penis that's what we all
said not a my grill
I like the joystick version better that
one in my head well we've man I have so
much more to get to but I'm kind of like
I'm feel like I'm getting sick don't
push it but I mean we have so much more
to get through it's ridiculous come on
just briefly cover this phase stuff cuz
it is pretty uh okay yeah actually have
a good take on this face thing so phase
the face clan is a huge gaming team
I guess they they came around there and
call of duty right is that right
I believe they started as a YouTube
channel of like they were like one of
the original 360 no-scope knew many
things but like on ironically I like the
MLG yeah yeah edits or whatever it was
like the real [ __ ]
right so but they've been around there
they have a huge name in gaming and a
lot of young gamers they have teams now
professional teams of all kinds want to
be on phase and recently there's been a
huge lawsuit by one of their top players
called T foo he's huge he's like the
size of ninja now playing fortnight and
he has come and laid a lawsuit against
phase for having predatory and illegal
contracts
he said his contract was so predatory he
had to sue fades now each of these
people have a huge fan base so the
debate is very dicey about he shed he
said this she said that and that's not
like the face guys have made tons of
videos talking about it teeth who's made
videos talking about it and I what I
want to do is I don't want to get in the
weeds with all this emotional I only
care about what the contract says and
the contract was elite okay so I'm gonna
just gonna look at the contract I'm
gonna give you my take on that so
because I do think that this is really
interesting and it is important because
this reminds me of when I was a young
youtuber like MC NS had they were so
predatory because it's unregulated you
have eager young kids that don't
understand what they're getting
themselves into vers a huge corporate or
huge people with lawyers who know how to
take advantage of people without any
regulations it's a recipe for people
getting wildly and and irresponsibly
taken advantage of and so it reminds me
of back then and then what it's really
not okay what these companies get away
with so basically I found God have the
contract so let's just look on this on
the basis of the contract that they
offered brand deals bought in by faze
clan phase gets 80% I mean that's that's
ridiculous right off the bat I never
heard I mean in traditional media
there's laws and regulations about this
to prepare as this predatory behavior
was just out of control
a manager a traditional manager an agent
they taking 10% 80% I mean what are we
talking about here
managers 20 but you could see 20 you
could see 30
I have partnerships so I have
partnerships most when I get an ad
through agency they'll take ten I have a
partnership the only one I have where
they take 20 they do so much work they
bring so much to the table that I'm
happy to give it to them but I but but
80% is untenable I mean that's just not
a feasible relationships extortion it's
it's it's ridiculous in-game sticker
merchandise I don't know what that even
means but that's 50/50 brand deals
brought in by the gamer 50% I mean again
they should be taking maybe like 5 or
10% if they brought in or even zero to
be if I'm being Frank appearance fees
50% prizes t foo gets 80% of tournaments
okay fine
so I mean this is really bad I don't
even know
I personally I'm people though saying
well why did why did they sign it you
know he's a he's a young kid in his
early 20s or late teens he's being
approached by one of the biggest he
gaming communities he wants to be a
member of phase and he's stupid he's
dumb
yeah he's eager and in the beginning you
may not know the numbers that are gonna
be involved and you may not know what's
normal what's not normal right exactly
you learn you learn as you do it I mean
he's talking to these face guys and
they're probably let him leading them on
this is this is normal this is what
everyone gets paid they might be saying
stuff now I'm speculating but this is
the kind of stuff that I've encountered
oh we can renegotiate we can revisit
these and stuff like that just be like
well don't worry about it you know let's
just get you in the door and we'll
figure it out now that's not even the
worst part the worst part is that the
contract has a specific termination
clause that forces T foo to sit on the
sidelines for six months and not
professionally pay any video games if he
gets fired for cause it says and it says
specifically I'll read it verbatim in
the event of a termination for a gamer
material breach gamer shall be
prohibited from playing video games
publicly online or in live tournaments
professionally for a period of six
months from the effective date of such
termination so what that means I mean
that flicks mine there Bay of Ceph
they're effectively saying if you breach
our contract we're gonna ruin your
professional gaming life I mean in six
months time that's like you're gonna be
left behind in that amount of time but
this is so predatory and it's borderline
evil I don't think we said but the
contract was for three years yes so
they're saying sure if you breach this
you cannot play professionally anything
anywhere for six months or we'll sue you
I mean this is just evil this is
predatory this is evil this is kind of
like their this is their trump card for
like oh if this guy ever gets unruly if
this guy ever gets out of hand then we
get this ultimate trump card of like
okay go ahead and leave we're gonna
sideline you for six months and sue you
if you try I mean that kind of clause
has no place in a contract in the real
world that would be so illegal so wildly
inappropriate for them to even include
this is is shocking it's appalling it's
a shame it's a disgrace it's an
embarrassment and I think that phase
should really read and I think this is
important for all of new media contracts
that are unregulated and not a lot of
eyeballs on it I think it calls for
extraordinary need though for regulation
but all these companies that that are
putting this kind of stuff in the
contract they need to be held reliable
so I don't know any of the backstory
about T foo I don't know what he said or
what he did or what fazed it I don't
know what but all I know is that stuff
like this in the contract NEET needs to
be brought out mm-hmm it needs to be
brought it needs to be talked about
because these are not huge corporations
these are vulnerable young bright young
stars rising stars who are building this
community for the betterment of all of
us the new media including phase and
phase to include terms like that is
truly it's truly heinous I mean it's
just heinous another issue that is
verified that that's the contract it is
verified I verified it I verified it was
somebody close to the situation who said
yes that is it so there was also other
things in there like that that they had
the right to reject any opportunities if
it didn't if they didn't agree to it so
they were limiting his opportunities to
like to other stuff I think that was one
of his main complaints yeah from what I
understand is that they were declining
things without even telling him about it
he would find out later things that he
was willing to do and wanted to make
money off of so everything aside I'm not
getting into the details I see people
saying oh well he's skyrocketed in
popularity after he joined phase or
phase tried to offer him a bunch of new
agreements that he kept refusing or that
toufu just wants to leave to start his
own organization I don't care about any
of that what I care about is what I'm
seeing here that was in the agreement
and that event of termination a gamer
shall be prohibited from playing video
games publicly or online in live
tournaments or professionally for a
period of six months effective from date
of termination that's a shame shame on
you for putting that in I mean give me a
break
that makes me sick
because you were just every youtuber we
would talk about there were all stuck in
contracts they didn't want to be in and
it was like well I'm stuck with these
guys for three years what am i what am I
gonna do now and right it was always
craziness it was tough and you know and
nobody I really understood either people
thought that being part of an MCN made
you more money that was in deal we
didn't even know why we were joining MCN
and we even had one bad experience that
these guys made eel cry I mean who was
it was any of them studio studio that's
their new name they were these guys a
little absolute worst they were studio
73 or something that evil I mean evil we
signed a contract and they changed the
terms on us after we already joined and
we're like yo what the hell yeah and it
was like we can't function in this
setting that you guys are setting us up
it has to be what we discussed
and they're like well you signed it so
bad I was like listen we signed we on on
we signed there was a misunderstanding
just release us then and we'll go part
our ways and he says listen this is the
world world it's time for you to grow up
you signed this contract and we are not
gonna let you out of it so you just need
to suck it up and you and we own you
know yeah and either started crying
because she couldn't believe this was
just so Eve is just like pure evil and
how it was too and so this [ __ ] exists
and my god this is worse than something
yeah collective digital studios that's
it and I'm that I got the bad press to
change your name to Studio 73 and I have
to say everyone 71 thing yet and I have
to say to this day shame on them I would
never recommend anyone to join that
never and really I mean this is worse
than anything I've ever seen
but then the beautiful thing was that
when we were completely didn't know what
to do we even made a tweet about it and
then they dropped us yeah all of a
sudden they could drop us out of the
contract yeah there's no problem well
that's exactly the situation right yeah
cuz the faze clan guys we're pushing
back against this TP that I'm saying is
a betrayal they backstab blah blah blah
or whatever and then the contract leaked
which let's be honest I mean T foo
probably leaked it right I mean well I
don't know but I sir we don't know that
but I mean if I'm out one worthy writer
there's a lot of people involved right
in face there's a lot right I guess it
could it could have been another person
within the organization but the second
it was released they completely changed
their tune and the phase guys are saying
oh yeah the contract was we knew it was
bad but we tried to make you better
right yeah yeah it helps to put people
on blast publicly sometimes you got to
do that you know and so dude these guys
should just shut the in my opinion after
seeing this I don't know about anything
of the beef between them personally but
bro this isn't does not look good
this does not look good and it's not
right it's not okay and shame on you and
your whole organization for putting that
in
shame on you that's all I say about it I
don't care about T foo I don't care
about face you do not put that in a
contract especially when you're dealing
with the kind of people you are who
aren't real well representative who
aren't well you are literally praying on
ignorant young people there's there's no
way to dispute that okay you're the one
who is in the beneficial position like
you know better you're the one who needs
to be you need to be guiding them of
course tief who's gonna want to get away
from this when he blows up he's not
psycho what do you expect them just to
be like alright well now that I'm making
millions of dollars I'm just gonna let
you take a tour stand in it shut up
idiots this makes me this makes me upset
you cannot defend this and anyone who
reads this I hope I it really does upset
me so that's it that's my old thing on
phase versity Foom I don't care about
anything else alright and I got a second
energy let's keep going Jake Paul verse
kotico cyberbullying man Jake Paul's a
[ __ ] idiot I know he was dumb but man
I didn't know he was this dumb people
like all of us I don't think he's
extraordinary and the sense that he's
more vicious or cruel than anyone so
this one guy is cutting Kody's hair and
part of a vlog and Jake shows up to
confront him for being a cyber bully
here we go way so apparently the
interview they're gonna spin coating
around I'm gonna go into this closet
where does Jake find these I'm gonna be
hiding in that beast yes ma'am and then
Jeff is going to ask Cody a question
about me and I'm going to come out you
know but like I do want to get a point
across that like that Cody you like you
are a piece of that's true I've heard
stories of like girls
crying and like literally being so hurt
by he's got a straw in his a little cup
nice catch in good I like it's ruined
their days there are weeks even I'm not
cool with that
what gives him the right to do that
he'll be so shocked like to me this guy
rare aesthetics by the way he just he'll
dick ride Jake for a full month just for
this little bloop rare aesthetics guys
give him the recognition he needs so he
can stop writing Jake stick this yes man
is is hurting my soul these are really
the most hurt people inside yeah yeah
sometimes I think Jake is smart but then
I see stuff like this I'm like wow he is
like so what he is like 50 IQ know
people that all right yeah
put all your intellectual mush together
[Music]
there we go and they're ready to debate
[Music]
[Music]
I love that this guy only got a jeff
like how am I supposed to find out who
he is this guy gets a Jeff Cody doesn't
get anything bro you sound like you're
12 for what the hell I don't like cyber
bullies your salary bullying oh man I
intentionally saved watching this for
the show and it's even worse than I
[ __ ] i think jake has gotten dumber I
think he's lost IQ points you know well
he clearly he clearly knows how awkward
this is cuz he can like barely even get
it out
nobody will I think he really thinks
he's getting him like a Chris Hanson you
know have a seat by the way he doesn't
realize that he's making fun of him like
I'm bought like bowling you what are you
a little [ __ ]
I think I'm balling Jake
like for real like there's kids out
there like I've met girls who you like
into like going in on you're like I
don't need to bring up their names to
cause drama for them you know what I'm
saying but like no we're seeing taking
[ __ ] that you knew like you sitting in
front of camera like actually can
resonate into people's hearts like
that's not cool by the way but it's like
who are you Jake to talk what have you
done for anyone so I made a little tweet
that I am gonna to my own horn here
because I thought I summarized it pretty
well so Jake Paul says yo we need to
discuss cyber bullying also Jake Paul
docks is possible on whose houses later
stuck up at gunpoint also Jake Paul
hosts a party where girls are drugged
also Jake ball brain washes kids to sell
immerse also Jake ball posting softcore
porn to 12 year olds and then it's one I
actually forgot is oh Jesus that is so
graphic that was a thumbnail I'm also
Jake Paul he did the mystery box scam
like only a month ago also this whole
destroying the house they were living in
Beverly Hills whatever that was yeah I
mean bro he we ruined the neighborhood
for all of his neighbors where is your
moral compass what are we talking about
bullying Europe yeah you know there are
things but dude he didn't he didn't
bully anybody yeah that's true well I
mean I don't know I'm sure he's been
accused of bullying a lot of his team
ten members said that he was a total
douche any bully though that's what I
left the I bet you the news guy who was
there trying to report felt like a
little I want to say bullied I mean Jake
what are you doing you really just need
to shut the [ __ ] up sometimes offensive
about it cuz it seems like his older
brother boys I'm like every that's true
Logan definitely strikes me as a bully
yeah I can imagine them growing up
you're a bully
probably should have yeah Logan's bro
yeah that's a good point though
give me the rope maverick I'm gonna show
soon everypony to the party yeah he said
sorry bro I'll shake your hand shake
down Jake so desperate to like pull some
kind of resolution he said sorry he said
I'm sorry for bullying you like he was
kind of goofing on him right and then
and then this guy's trying to set up a
joke cuz I watched his video he made it
he made a edit I think they pre-planned
this joke so it was like he would be
like Kankan Cody come and then Jake's
supposed to be like no and he's like oh
well whatever but he so he kept this in
he edited it so poorly he makes the host
look like an idiot washes why did he
even include that he's not not taking it
he's just confused all have ominous
music going yeah I don't know why he
okay yeah it's funny
right like you clearly huge audience
where you're spreading so much did you
think about this Jake before you decided
to come in here and debate in you know
yeah it's very uncomfortable
yes Fred so much negativity like okay
what kind of content do you want to see
Jake smile more eyelid we all just need
to say hi everyone smile Maura
I was literally scrolling through that
tweet I made and saw a thumbnail so
heinous his fans are so young hello dude
what the [ __ ] you literally want a fight
you literally have sexual tension with
your mom
Jake my cyber bullying him right now
also your Jake Paul hello what's new
everybody makes fun of you on YouTube
what look did you not get the memo
you're Jake Paul dude look at you you
look like a you look like a member of a
boyband that didn't get the cut not a
good line no I just cyber bullied myself
should we keep watching this is pretty
cringy very deep Jake very Jeep where's
the line between funny and F dub there
you have it
Jake cyber bully intern what is this oh
yeah yeah I saw this this this evening
he's cyber bullying an intern he goes
please read if you're an aspiring music
producer engineer he says if you are a
young aspiring music producer and
engineer please read we are need of a
full-time producer engineer who will
mainly act as an engineer first that
doesn't sounds like
a big gig right then he goes on this
will be an internship and will provide
you with real life experience
connections exposure than a whole lot of
fun which I don't work on fun fun
doesn't feed me idiot full-time we wanna
so I'm like Jake your team you're
supposed to be the super millionaire you
can't page someone what the [ __ ] is this
it might be a paid internship it does it
say I'm paid to me when he says I think
it is cuz yang we will provide you with
a real life except you're right it's
unpaid I guarantee because when he says
I'm looking for a music producer
engineer we are in need of a full-time
in-house producer engineer that sounds
like a job yeah full times this is an
internship yeah well I mean anyway I'm
trying to get that full-time in-house
producer is also an intern bro you can
afford to pay him you cyber bullying
yeah goddamn right yep we have a lot of
fun out here in h3 HT podcasts don't yes
we do you guys havin fun back there
we're chillin yeah how about you guys
oh yeah you guys [ __ ] suck
[Laughter]
I guess I gotta are here I guess I'm the
one entertaining here moving on how's
that guys can you hold the show for a
minute no I love you guys but sometimes
you kill me in all seriousness that was
way crazier than I ever could have
imagined what me asking you guys to
participate on show the [ __ ] Jake
Paul video like I said I didn't watch it
because I kind of wanted it I wanted to
see it fresh on the show and just from
the description I kind of had an image
of what it would be and that was so much
more awkward just kinda standing around
I second that
very cranky well actually you know what
let me pull it back up then because I
feel like when you have the full context
of what he's trying to do you can
appreciate that kind of just cut to the
chase but here he explains what he's
doing thanks mom I'm just kidding kind
of not really I'm about to confront like
one of my biggest haters 28-year old
wannabe comedian kotico or I saw this
car when we was working at full skirts
which is like community network as like
a little back-end tech developer and now
he just shits on people yeah okay
welcome to the project
imagine imagine to them 15 16 17 18 19
year old 20 year old that doesn't have
as much self-confidence like what that
would do to them and why that's why like
Oh even you he's his feelings I know
he's doing it for someone you've got a
whole time I'm not owned I'm not gonna
logic he's doing it for everybody else
he thought this confrontation went so
well he went made a a summer so we cut
the cameras off and you had a longer
deeper conversation and I genuinely felt
like Cody has zero remorse he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's not gonna change his
ways didn't work I really thought it
would his his processes or his thoughts
and everything is if he faces enough
backlash I believe that social media
creators won't change if they are a bad
person unless they even know that
honestly thought that you were gonna
cause a backlash against Cody Co with
this video you truly have the lowest IQ
on this planet you are so dumb from
making a few jokes about it also like
he's trying to show examples of Cody
being a bully and he shows him like
making fun of minions I [ __ ] you not
Cody's going minions who likes those and
he's showing that as an example I was
like dude I used to give J credit for
being somewhat intelligent business-wise
what
I mean I could do both I don't
understand how he hadn't learned the
lesson to like when he came on this
podcast what almost two years ago now
the reaction to his appearance was like
largely positive because it seemed like
he was just kind of owning the criticism
and and you know not quite embracing the
meme but you know he was
self-deprecating he was kind of humble
while I was here and everything and it
seemed like that's when somebody shits
on you if that's how you react to it
people actually like you more you know
what I mean yeah well doing this right
just makes it makes me want to make fun
of you even more right now I mean my
cyberbully the [ __ ] right you know
you know that's did you hit that you hit
the nail on the head there Dan because I
feel like the charm of Jake was that
everyone showed him and he just took it
in stride and it didn't bother him right
but now he's mr. cyber bully and it's
not a good look especially when he tries
to pass it off like it's not he's it's
not about him just imagine somebody else
how that's insecure I'm secure but
somebody else might be insecure I think
anytime Jake tries to articulate a point
he should stop and not be a sexual
predator gets accused of you know it's
not my dream come on you look like four
no eyes see that was a better one than
the boy thank you i yeah thank you
all right well moving on Game of Thrones
I got a lot of grievances for games of
Thrones here Game of Thrones this is
something that I've been invested in for
such a long time I love the story of the
characters I knew in my heart that this
final episode would be irredeemably the
worst thing ever
did anybody like it let me start with no
no and Ian you said you were more
neutral neutral neutral to slightly
negative onions part I was big thumbs
down I was a shoo-in you what did you
like about it or did you not read the
books or I mean what were you did you
just thought it was fine how else they
can do it what was your tape yeah I
never read the books and I checked out
like a few episodes ago so I was just
like it's alright it's cool
well okay spoiler alerts obviously I
think everybody knows what
now so bran becomes king and that's just
so dumb
it's so dumb in so many different ways
I'm gonna break it down for you guys
here I'm very passionate about this but
before I get into it this tweet I loved
this woman thinks that she says a lot of
disappointed reactions on this website
about bran becoming King reminds me why
we live in a society with so many with
so few maintainable opportunities for
disabled people this is meant to be oh
yeah this person thought that it because
he's disabled that people aren't happy
this isn't meant to be comment on the
show itself or the character reading I
have not been a long follower and
recently caught up some because thinking
that a disabled person don't deserve
chances because we can't do anything as
restrictive settings perpetuates ableism
it's why we got unfairly shut out of
them Plus shut up no we don't like bran
becoming King because it is stump and it
doesn't make sense can you imagine
I hate disabled people that's why you
shouldn't be king alright y'all I've got
a whole list so come with me okay I just
have a list of [ __ ] I hated about this
episode one the unsullied leave the
continent yet John is banished to the
north
John is banished to the north because he
kills Daenerys the unsullied his arm
Daenerys his army says he must be
punished they're the only ones they care
they leave before John yet John still
has to go live his whole life on the
Nights Watch
why so dumb nobody [ __ ] cares bran is
the king why is brand the king I feel
like they literally only did that to
subvert expectations they didn't build
it up they didn't justify it only three
episodes ago in Winterfell they want
brand to be the Lord of Winterfell he
says I can't be the Lord of Winterfell I
can't be anything anymore
I'm the three-eyed Raven now while the
sudden he's like yeah [ __ ] I'm King and
he even has the super smug
out-of-character answer tyrion says
would you like to be king and bran says
why do you think I came all this way but
all of a sudden he's mr. [ __ ] cool
also Brenda broken and the broken
bran
three-eyed Raven brand the seeing brand
the wise anything ran the broke-ass nerd
brand alaimo how would you call your
king the broken I don't know that name
just I couldn't get over it brand the
broke-ass [ __ ] lame undeserving how
about Arya who trained all the show for
this ability to take someone's face and
go and do anything and kill anyone she
didn't use that ability not once the
entire season
we built that up for nothing in fact
Arya goes all the way into the red keep
with the Hound turns back finds the
white horse like it's some kind of
prophetic thing we thought maybe Brandon
said the horse guess who did nobody
pointless no reason for it
arias character was pointless poorly
written nothing happened
you built this character up to have all
these beautiful backstories and threads
to go and all these different places
what does she do sail west because
nobody knows what's West are you [ __ ]
kidding me
you have dragons you have magic you have
boats and none of you [ __ ] has ever
sailed west what the [ __ ] about her
brother that sees everything oh yeah and
how about bran who could literally see
everything nobody's been West shut up
nobody's been west all the sudden she's
our she's Arya the Explorer but she's
not even here to explore that's not even
part of that's not even a major part of
her character she wanted to become
stronger she wanted to escape says what
is she explored that doesn't make sense
shows I'm going west why why would she
leave her family the whole point of her
story arc was to reunite with her family
and protect them and now she's going
west what [ __ ] you also everyone leaves
Bryan alone what is he gonna do by
himself brand the worthless yeah
the broken brand yeah here we go what
was the point of John even being Aegon
Targaryen what was the point of it at
all it never amounted nothing to
anything and never went anywhere what
was the point of anyone finding out
various was writing notes to everyone in
the whole kingdom that John is Aegon
whatever happened nothing
ever happen with that you know he never
did anything he literally was just sent
back north as a punishment for murdering
the queen who the only person who cared
about it was the unsullied who already
sailed off
why should John go to the north when he
is the rightful king yeah and everybody
knows he's the rightful he has the
following people already want him to
he's the one guy who is well respected
is battle-tested rue knows how to rule
has groomed his whole life on how to
rule and besides all that is the
rightful king why is he going to the
north when everybody wants him to be
king and the only people who don't want
him to be king already [ __ ] left the
entire continent let me ask you also
this tyrion who has proven to be one of
the dumbest characters possible in the
last two seasons finally commits the
biggest Coupe de gras of all time of
stupidity
he's comes walking out in chains in
front of grey worm having been a
conspirator and the murder of his Queen
Daenerys and he says you know who should
be king the one with the best story
seriously Tyrion and all of your travels
and all everything you've been through
you've decided that the person should be
king is not the one who's capable not
the one who's smart not the one who was
the people the interests of the people
at heart no he says the one who should
be king is the won't the best story
sorry what the [ __ ] does that have to do
with your ability to rule that's the
point of your character to come with to
that the best story so he says that's
why branch should be the king cuz he has
the best story [ __ ] stop right there
bran doesn't even have the best story
[ __ ] you Jon has the best story by far
he died and came back he died he was
living his whole life a lie he was Aegon
Targaryen raised by Ned Stark as his own
son everyone thought Ned Stark was like
a perfect guy except that he cheated on
his wife nobody could believe that guess
what he was raising his sister's son the
whole time to cover her deep secret it
was John the whole time he was the
Targaryen that everyone was looking for
he rode a dragon
he killed the Queen the girl he loved to
save the realm guys he is the true king
and you can tell me bran who fell have a
[ __ ] window and sat quietly in a
wheel chair the whole time has the best
story even by that stoop
metric which doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense he does even have the best story
Tyrion continues to be the worst
character ever he went from being the
smart wise all-knowing character that
everybody trusts and loved to being an
absolute nitwit who should have been
thrown off the side of the [ __ ]
castle by Daenerys because he's useless
and he's an idiot his career doesn't
make any [ __ ] sense why didn't anyone
even allow him to make that decision let
alone the unsullied who would have put
his [ __ ] head on a spike
knowing them allowed Tyrion to make the
decision for brand to be king and then
everybody else just goes along with it
how dumb is that okay the what do you
call the people that the from the iron
the iron island they go
she made an allegiance the iron island
girl made a legion area for to Danny and
Tyrion just goes no no no you know what
bran a stark should be king because he
has an interesting story and then two
minutes later she goes I suggested
democracy let the people vote yeah yeah
they all laughed at him they're okay
with that yeah [ __ ] democracy oh and by
the way what is the point of Sam's story
how much did that guy go through just to
be a [ __ ] Meister for bran the broken
like seriously that is what it all led
to give me a [ __ ] break
Sam ended up being a useless little
[ __ ] himself Tyrion is the biggest
useless [ __ ] brand his character
doesn't even make any [ __ ] sense and
everyone at that table is a punk [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] okay how about the Prince
from Dorne who magically shows up at the
end of the story and also on all the
sudden is like okay yeah let's have bran
be king because he has an interesting
story meanwhile his stark sister who
says Oh up for me I'm gonna be
independent in the north and everyone's
cool with that too so now the Starks are
in charge of the north and the entire
kingdom and everyone's just like I
because brand has an interesting story
yo and you just I didn't even think
about this till now but the the great
tragic Yara yeah you pointed out she she
was only there because she had the deal
with Daenerys yes the deal was that the
Iron Islands were gonna become
independent yes so why would so Sansa
gets to leave but she doesn't yeah and
she didn't and do you know why damn
that's do you know why because bran has
a
interesting story good point oh yeah
there was one scene of John killing
Danny and then it cuts from that to
everyone sitting there already knowing
what happened that's it came from
Winterfell that would take months to get
there yeah yeah I think it's implied
there was a long time skip but that's up
I mean everything was so [ __ ] rushed
it was I never did that though so Danny
who's the major the most impactful
character of the whole story the mother
of dragons she is slayed by John her
lover she dies and in the very next
scene they're laughing and goofing
around they're her death has no impact
it has a negative impact it is so not
impactful it is so pointless and
worthless I mean how could you [ __ ] this
up you can see that the writers these
bozos who created this show have
literally checked out this is a spit in
the face of fans I hate it I hate it it
doesn't make any sense it's so bad it's
so bad dude these two idiots who made
the show just ran off to make Star Wars
they literally didn't give a [ __ ] about
how this story ended it doesn't make
sense
bran has a better story what the hell I
love to when Tyrians like explaining his
rationale for why he has a good story
and he's saying things like he's the
three-eyed Raven does other than like
one or two characters do any anyone get
that meeting have any idea what the [ __ ]
no in fact we don't even know what that
we don't know what that means
bran doesn't even know what that means
for all I know it doesn't mean anything
in fact during the long night when the
when the king of winter got bitched out
by Arya
we were wicked the night King got Bishop
Arya we were being like you know brand
they're gonna explain he was up to some
[ __ ] he was doing stuff no he was
sitting there uselessly the whole
[ __ ] time he Worf worked into some
crows what he literally did not cool er
if he was like because the thing is it
kind of leaves it with this sort of it's
not explicit at all but like this sort
of implication that bran was puppet
mastering everything like you said when
he's out of character is like that's why
I'm here or whatever so I think what
that was was like a last-ditch pathetic
attempt by the writers to give some
meaning right at all to their
writing when actually there wasn't any
that's not brands character that is just
not brands character if they didn't set
it up that way they didn't put any clues
into it that literally in the episode
before he said I'm nothing I can't rule
anymore this person said it greatly
Nathan he I don't know what it's from
but he says so Jon Jon Snow was a
Targaryen for no reason bran became the
three-eyed Raven for no reason Danny had
an amazing did amazing things for three
seasons for no reason Prince who was
promised no reason everyone you wanted
to team up for eight season teams up for
no reason
everyone you wanted to die dies for no
reason Brandon Stark this character no
one gives a [ __ ] about for three season
his king why no reason that's why I've
watched Game of Thrones since 2011 for
no reason at all
harsh but a shame because it was so well
made and it's just I loved a word that
they created and the characters and
actors and the outfits like everything
about it is so well made and then the
story was just so I think that's
important to say because I saw I think
it was sonses character that
what's-her-name so she was saying that
she thought she was disgusted by
everyone's reaction because everyone
worked so hard and again a great
variation to remake it with a million
and it's not in it and again it's not
about you everyone says I say I mean
that when Daenerys attack King's Landing
it was it was some of the most
incredible footage I have ever seen on
television or movie or cinema I mean the
show was just amazing and the work they
put in was just amazing the acting it
was breath everything about the show was
amazing and he's done the reason I am
swimming pissed off is because he's too
[ __ ] bozos the HP I wanted tenth
season and these two [ __ ] who got their
heads way too big wanted to run off and
make Star Wars and they this this
cultural masterpiece this important this
was an important piece of cultural
literature they didn't they betrayed
George RR Martin's vision they betrayed
the fans in HBO because they wanted to
go make a Star Wars movie now mark my
words I guarantee you to this day
everything they make from now on will be
[ __ ] because we are going to see their
true talent as filmmakers
the
were only good because they were working
with George or Martin they had the
source material to work from and the
show was fantastic because they're able
to work with that but now everything
they make is gonna be [ __ ] because their
true colors gonna come out they're gonna
go make a Star Wars trilogy
it's gonna be ass and after that people
are not gonna work with them and they're
gonna go down as talentless hacks that
by some fluke made this incredible show
but that they ruined the ending and I do
think that they have tarnished the
legacy of what was otherwise one of the
most incredible and important television
sagas in a modern time I mean really and
it still is despite their best efforts
to ruin it but that that that that
petition is not against all those crew
members work in fact I would say it's in
support of them their hard work those
guys [ __ ] on everyone's hard work by
ending it hastily the way they did
that's my take on it yeah I'm upset
here's George are Martin talking about
it I don't know we could have gone to
eleven twelve thirteen seasons exactly I
guess they wanted a life you wanted to
well you know if you've read that my
novels you know there was enough
material for four more seasons they made
certain cuts what but that's fine we
have five other shows five prequels and
development that are based on other
periods in the history of Westeros there
you go he's not he's being cordial but
you can tell he ain't happy why wouldn't
they just pass it to someone else
because they had it they had an
exclusive agreement George said that he
never wanted to make have his books be
made into media unless it was the
perfect people and he met these two guys
he thought they were right he'd liked
them and he gave them the sole authority
to make this show so when they left
HBO couldn't hire someone else to finish
it they literally [ __ ] on everybody
what's the point of the Ice King nothing
by the way also notice after this
episode there was no commentary you know
how they always suck their own think
about
now anything for it yeah cuz we talked
about it last time guys I want to see
what you have to say about this you know
what's the perfect little twist of bad
writing at the end branch shows up
tyrians there with their new circle and
what who shows up are the most worthless
pathetic group of people including bran
by the way who started as a secondary
character that was charming who became
this
I think George are Martin said the brand
bran was never meant to be a central
character and the producers liked him so
they kept the network wanted to bring
more of him bran who has betrayed Tyrion
at every level possible is now his
master of coin sitting there this guy is
this writing is so pathetic that also
presupposition positions that Tyrion
appointed Bronn to have a seat at the
table of as master of coin yeah material
is literally the dumbest most useless
character in this story by far these
past two seasons I go further back than
that but yeah definitely most
deteriorated from where that character
once was you know one of the highlights
of the show at one point also while the
Dothraki kind of forgot that whoever
kills their cow becomes Kyle yeah
remember actually all the lore and story
building
the Dothraki when you kill their cow you
become the cow because they respect
power and strength
Danny was their cow John killed Danny
they would by their own traditions
follow John right yeah idiot that they
just disappeared they didn't even
address what happened to them they just
wouldn't raped and pillaged also brand
said you may be able to know where the
dragon is and then there's nothing there
like brands like any reports of where
the dragon is no I'll be I might be able
to follow I might be able to find him
okay I felt like that had a look at dark
implication too right he's got what he's
gonna warg it so now he has the dragon
to like rule with an iron fist wasn't he
supposed to already war get in the
battle that was the whole [ __ ] point
of everybody contributing something you
just you can't just keep hinting stuff
and then it doesn't go anywhere like
what was the white horse
why did Arya go on a white horse and
then
next episode starts with her walking the
horse is not even done believably bad
writing
unbelievably unforgivably by a variety
in fact so much that the character who
plays brand when he fret first read read
the ending script he's thought it was a
prank he said he thought he was being
pranked
yikes no dude that's for the real ending
also these idiots cannot stop how hard
is it when you're shooting a scene watch
this they had a cop in the previous
scene okay cutie there's a water bottle
and the final scene of the show the
[ __ ] water bottle that's what they're
doing in the season finale guys whoops
that just gives you an idea of how
[ __ ] checked out I bet you they
weren't even there they're out there
sucking Jar Jar Binks [ __ ] yeah exactly
we collected a I'm so upset you guys I'm
so upset about this it's seriously if
you told me Bram becomes king John kills
Danny it's not even just that one coming
it's like how you got there everything
happened so fast yeah I agree
have any motion when then he died I
wasn't even feeling anything it was
literally nothing there was all these
emotional music and then the next thing
is like you're supposed to laugh and
like II don't even it just had no effect
I was incredulous when the dragon just
randomly like nukes the [ __ ] Iron
Throne so [ __ ] corny and again I
thought maybe that was a state line or a
statement that they're gonna go with no
King right and but then actually all it
ends up being is a handicap ramp for
brand here we we could we we gathered a
bunch of memes because we weren't the
only ones who are upset by this actually
I mean it's usually with these kind of
things it's pretty divisive but I mean
outside of the woman who thinks it's cuz
brands handicapped
seems like most people are [ __ ] on
the ending including the cast oh yeah
this was great Sansa's like Brant can't
reproduce absolutely no what's Sansa
Brandt's dick doesn't work who has a
better story than Brant Tyrion how about
every single person in the show yeah
there's nothing in the world more
powerful than a good story we kind of
forgot stories are supposed to be good
Sam what if we invented democracy
everyone else you dumb [ __ ]
oh yeah Daenerys is my queen bran should
be king hi
Tyrion brand the broken brand yeah
actually just Brandon school Tyrion bran
the busted up no okay Terry and bran the
wheelie wheelie legs go feely
no feeling no feeling what's west of
Westeros I don't know no one knows its
brand okay yeah John yeah yeah yeah when
you this was a very popular one when you
don't contribute to the group project
and still get a name its brand yeah
brand a little weird we appear to be
missing a master of whispers you
literally see everything by the way why
all the sudden is brand mr. like regal
like he knows how to like [ __ ] you've
just been wandering around in the snow
you idiot you did in the early seasons
rule but he's not brain anymore that's
true right right best way to kill Cersei
one Jamie kills her Knight Cain kills
her Arya kills her drug on kills her
bran wargs into number fifteen brand
wargs and to Cersei and commit suicide
146 she gets pneumonia and dies 1672
gets trampled by rocks Cersei and Jaime
could have moved if they survived just a
little bit to the right
sir Jamie died while telling Cersei that
he was in love with Brienne who was
superhot in the end that's what she
wrote and the King's you know there's a
little book that she writes the story
couldn't handle the snap of her sweet
puss so he crawled back to his skanky ex
Sarah I couldn't make you [ __ ] like your
sister Jamie you gold fisted loser me
watching Brianna close the book without
letting the ink dry there was actually a
great line someone said Brianne closing
the book without letting the ink dries
the perfect metaphor for this season mmm
we set sail for Nath and leave seven
kingdoms forever is he gone I think so
Lil Jon you can stay here is cool now
yeah exactly
and now our batch has ended these two
idiots this was actually a great one
it's got a Rubik's Cube
George's book and then these bozos just
painted over the night of it to make it
look like it was complete that's
actually really clever eh yeah yeah I
like that one
what do we say to HBO on Monday
unsubscribe you know what it's not HBO's
fault they wanted to do ten seasons I
like HBO I'm gonna stay subscribe to HBO
I respect HBO for creating this they
still have great shows they still have
great programming I'm just upset that
this cultural hallmark really was just
laid to rest I mean it ended much like
Danny pathetically quickly and without a
single tear I was going through mourning
to be honest over the past last several
episodes I was getting sad that it was
ending but whenever we would talk about
it off air you were like legitimately
sad like not even angry like just sad
about it I was yeah and and I wasn't
able to really come cope with the loss
of this story in these characters
because I'm I'm dealing with what is
just utterly like pathetic writing I
mean really just like like middle school
grade writing finish the story and we've
got a lot more about let's let's save it
I want to do a um no meme left behind
soon and there's there's a lot of really
great material here yeah I feel like I
was [ __ ] this whole episode man I was
I was on one I was like
but there you have it that's the HT
podcast I do guys enjoyed I guess when I
drink tea I turn into a [ __ ]
that's it that's all oh and we made a
new video on a shoe issue productions
ela is pregnant as Frick she is gonna be
give birth any day now my back really
hurts
I can barely sit you know we're at the
point where like I mean this could be
the last episode before him I mean yeah
happen at any moment people were
wondering we are still I'm gonna come in
by myself and just update people don't
think it'll be nice just get out of the
house we're at the hospital but yeah but
we'll play by here but my intention is
to come do it solo just do a short one
like an hour or something just talk
about stuff maybe bring some footage
video someday village review with the
baby
not like you [ __ ] out the babies
like home video yeah yeah you look
concerned guys have a blessed weekend
TGIF and God as written in the Bible
thank God it's Friday we love the
weekend we love our crew our cast Dan
and Zach Ian by the way is been making
these cold opens he's doing a fantastic
job thinking of grooming and to become
one of our editors so he's even though
he may be getting a promotion soon he
will be in turn himself forever by title
that's true he's like so loud like but
yeah I want people to know that he is
getting promoted he's being recognized
within the ranks of the company but he's
still in the intern forever in our
hearts matter thank you for your service
dan I mean come on Dan the producer who
you kidnap it's the Ross of the rock you
know what I'm saying
we got a way I want to give it away but
we gotta do something with that the Ross
thank you guys for watching thank you
for your support I thank you all for
being here with us and listening to me
ramble
I got more there's more to come
I wonder if there's gonna be more drama
I feel like it'll never end
bang it has got to end I kind of would
like it why you know what I mean I don't
I think it's most dramatic like month of
my whole career so it's nice not being
involved in it though it's so that's
whatever it's a very stinkin that is not
involved all right guys thank you all so
much we do love you appreciate you for
being a part of the show and being here
with us we will see you next week until
then have a fantastic week and a great
week and I had love you guys
[Music]